la tranquillité à sa plus simple
expression une promenade sur l'eau un
canot
mais cela biren maritime de 6 km n'est
pas naturel détrompez vous il a été créé
de toutes pièces il y a plus de dix ans
quand j'ai vu sauce d'aplatir dauger dit
on va essayer de combats ont fait comme
les castors mois creuser des canal pis
là ils vont inonder mois pour espionner
canal sont un peu jaloux en cadeau puis
le soir de la bid la biodiversité à
grandeur monsieur leclerc savais que ce
ne serait pas chose facile de vendre ce
type d'aventuré aux touristes comment
elle veut égaliser un état parce que
c'est pas pour maintenant quand même
dans un sport et c'est cet envoi d'un
sombre puis devenant peur des mots chez
des bébés
tant qu'à faire là contre délibéré et
puis là à chaque intersection on a mis
des répliques animal que foot identifie
c'est la première chose que tu as besoin
de savoir un environnement ne peut pas
détruire d'identifier laventure peut se
vivre un canot en planche à pagaie ou
encore en pédalo armés de leur carte
les visiteurs sillonnent le plan d'eau à
leur rythme tout en découvrant la faune
et la flore du marais un phénomène
naturel surprend également les
aventuriers la lentille d'eau il s'agit
d'un tapis vert que l'on retrouve sur
une bonne portion du parcours et qui
donne l'impression de naviguer sur du
gazon cette lentille et riches en
nourriture et en insectes ce qui est
primordial pour une marée en santé avec
ce projet unique michel leclerc voulait
faire vivre l'étape d'apaisement que
peut procurer un tel écosystème le fait
de tana la nature c'est relax un my name
des médecins ont prescrit présentement à
défendre un marshall en forêt c'est ça
ta pas et ça permet de retrouver ton
vite parce que tout ce qui venant taux
est beaucoup moins rapide que toi tu
acceptes permet de taper dans l'axé
s'est souvent le rite convives avaient
envie on est rapide quand arrive un
milieu naturel comme ça tout est à la
clau les oiseaux chantent les
grenouilles croatie ainsi de suite tu
peux voir autre chose et c'est sûr que
sa relaxe
quand tu sors de la ville lundi 8 août
c'est pour ça qu'elle mondiale en nature
localement on vient de créer en forêt
pour retrouver dans la
leurs moyens derrière ici que se
terminait à radio canada wakefield en
outaouais